في اخبار عاجله افاد مراسل الجزيره ان
قوات كبيره من جيش واليات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مصحوبه
بجرافك مدينه طول كرم بالضفه الغربيه من
محورها الغربي في الاثناء دوت صفارات
الانذار في مخيمي طول كرم ونور شمس معنا
من طول كرم مراسل الجزيره ليث جعار ليث ما
الذي جرى على
الارض نعم بالفعل بدات عمليه اقتحام واس
لمدينه طول كرم من الجهه الغربيه للمدينه
من تحديدا من بوابه 104 وما تسمى بتسني
عوز باتجاه مدينه طول كرم ومن ثم على
امتداد شارع السكه حيث نتواجد في هذه
الاثناء وصولا الى المخيمين مخيم طول كرم
ومخيم نور شمس ما يزيد او تم رصد ما يزيد
عن 25 اليه عسكريه برفقه جرافه وايضا
برفقه جرافه من طراز دي ناين والمعروفه
هذه الاثناء نعم ليث وانت تتحدث وانت
تتحدث ليث يعني لو تكمل لنا هذه المعطيات
الميدانيه التي تجري الان ولكن نريد من
المصور ان يوسع الكاميرا باتجاه الصوره
الاوسع علنا نرى اكثر ما يعني ما هو
[موسيقى]
خلفك نعم يعني نحن الان ننتظر وصول
الاليات العسكريه وبالفعل بدا بدات
العمليات او الاليات العسكريه تصل في هذه
الاثناء تباعا الى هذه المنطقه جرافات
اسرائيليه جديده الان وصلت الى شارع السكه
في هذه اللحظات كما تشاهدون في هذه الصوره
قبل قليل ايضا كان هناك جرافه من طراس دي
9 وصلت الى محيط المخيم مرت من هذا الطريق
والان على ما يبدو جرافتين برفقه عدد من
الاليات العسكريه التي تص صل في هذه
اللحظات الى المنطقه تشاهدون في هذه
الصوره الان جرافات من طراز دي 9
والمعروفه بقوتها التدميريه الهائله وهذه
هي الثانيه بالفعل التي تصل الى مدينه طول
كرم وايضا برفقه جرافات اخرى واليات
عسكريه اسرائيليه عديده وصلت الى هذه
المنطقه في هذه اللحظات نرصد اذا عدد من
الاليات العسكريه والجرافات الاسرائيليه
التي تصل في هذه الاثناء تباعا الى دوار
او شارع السكه في هذه الاثناء في مدينه
طولكرم من بوابه 104 او ما تسمى تسان عوز
في هذه اللحظات وسط انفجارات لعشرات
العبوات الناسفه في محيط المخيم وايضا في
هذه الاثناء تم تفجير عبوه ناسفه باليات
الاحتلال العسكريه هنا في هذه المنطقه كما
تشاهدون عبر الصوره وه لتحرك واقتحام موسع
لجيش الاحتلال في هذه اللحظات اذا هناك
اطلاق نار في هذه الاثناء على ما يبدو من
الاليات العسكريه اذا نرصد دخول جديد
لاليات الاحتلال في هذه اللحظات الى مدينه
طول كرم ومخيم او وصولا الى مخيم طول كرم
في هذه الاثناء عشرات الاليات العسكريه في
هذه اللحظه تم رصد ما يزيد عن عره اليات
عسكريه
من بينها جرافه جرافه من طراز دي 9
والاخرى جرافه عاديه لازاله
وفتح الطرقات الان اشتباكات مسلحه نعم في
هذه اللحظات اشتباكات مسلحه تدور مع
الاليات ما بين قوات الاحتلال والشبان
الذين او المقاومين الذين يتصدون لهذا
الاقتحام في هذه اللحظات اذا اطلاق نار
بالفعل في هذه في هذا الطريق وباتجاه
اثناء توجه الاحتلال باتجاه مخيم نور شمس
ومخيم طول كرم هذا ما كنت اريد ان اسالك
عنه الطريق التي نشاهدها الان التي مرت
بها هذه الجرافه وخلفها مجموعه المدرعات
تذهب يعني من اين الى
اين نعم خرجت من بوابه 104 وما تسمى بتسني
عوز وهو معبر يصل مدينه طولكرم
بالداخل متل وصولا الى وسط المدينه وهو
شارع السكه باتجاه المخيمين مخيم نور شمس
ومخيم طول كرم هذا الشارع على طول ما يزيد
عن 500 متر حتى تصل الاليات العسكريه الى
وسط المخيمين مخيم طول كرم ومخيم نور شمس
بالتزامن مع هذا الاقتحام هناك اقتحام
وايضا ومشاه من حي الرشيد الى الجنوب من
مخيم نور شمس ب يعني تم رصد عشرات الجنود
الراجلين الذين اقتحموا مشاه الى المنطقه
وصولا الى المنطقه الغربيه
للمخيم من اجل البدء بعمليه الاغلاق
والحصار الذي يفرضه الاحتلال على المخيمات
الجنود المشاء الذين دخلوا من الجهه
الغربيه توحي بان هذا الاقتحام هو متجه
نحو مخيم نور شمس الى الشرق من المدينه
وبهذا يعني على ما يبدو ان الاليات
العسكريه قبل قليل او جزء من الاليات
العسكريه التي خرجت في البدايه وهي ما
تزيد عن 25 اليه عسكريه برفقه جرافتين قد
وصلت بالفعل الى مخيم نور شمس شرق المدينه
وقامت او تقوم في هذه اللحظات
بمحاصيل وسط اشتباكات مسلحه تسمع على
الهواء مباشره بين الفينه والاخرى وتفجير
للعب الناسفه باليات الاحتلال العسكريه
يذكر ان هذا الاقتحام هو الاقتحام الثاني
خلال هذا الاسبوع نعم اه تفضل تفضل يعني
هو ذات المحور الذي اريد ان اتحدث بك مع
عنه هذه الاقتحامات المتكرره يعني بالنسبه
لطول كرم ومخيمها او مخيمها
تحديدا نعم يعني منذ يومين كان هناك
اقتحام اخر وتم رصده ومتابعته ايه انسحب
الاحتلال في ساعات الصباح الاولى ي خلال
هذا الاسبوع هذا الاقتحام الثاني وخلال 10
ايام هذا حقيقه هو الاقتحام الثالث الذي
ايه تشهده او يشهده مخيم نور شمس في اطار
ايه ال محاوله كما يدعي الاحتلال القضاء
على العناصر المسلحه
وا انهاء ملف المقاومين المتصاعد في شمال
الضفه الغربيه المحتله
ليث قياسا على ما جرى في الاقتحامات
السابقه وهي ليست ببعيده ومتكرره خلال
الايام القليله الفائته كما ذكرت ما ضخامت
هذه القوه التي شاهدنا بانها دخلت وتلك
الاخرى التي تحدث بانها دخلت من اتجاه اخر
قوه المشات التي ايضا دخلت وطوقت المكان
من مدخل
اخر نعم يعني الاحت يسعى من خلال هذه
الاقتحامات الى ال يعني انهاء او محاوله
انهاء ملف المقاومين في مخيم نور شمس
بالتزامن مع توجه الاعلام العالمي نحو ما
يحدث من جرائم في قطاع غزه فبالتالي يسعى
الاحتلال لاستغلال هذه الفرصه ومحاوله
للقضاء على العناصر المسلحه في كل اقتحام
يحاول الاحتلال استهداف الفلسطينيين
استهداف تحديدا المقاومين وا ايه بحجه انه
يريد القضاء على العناصر او من يشكل خطر
على وجود المستوطنات والمستوطنين وتحرك
المستوطنين وجيش الاحتلال في شمال الضفه
الغربيه المحتله يسعى من خلال ذلك لاقتحام
المخيمات الفلسطينيه وتحديدا مخيمات طول
كرم مخيم نور شمس
ومخيم طول كرم في في سبيل القضاء وانهاء
هذا الملف الذي يعتبره الاحتلال انه طال
ده وانه
اتسعت به رقعه الاستهداف للمستوطنات ونقاط
ونقاط العسكريه لجيش الاحتلال قبل حوالي
ساعتين من الان كان هناك استهداف لجيش
الاحتلال بعبوه ناسفه وبصلي من الرصاص عند
بوابه شويكه الى الشمال من مدينه طول كرم
طيب ليث وايضا يعني طبقا لما كان يجري من
هذه الاقتحامات وكنا قد تابعنا وانت تتحدث
للتول بان هناك سياره اسعاف قد مرت خلفك
كيف تبدو امكانيه وصول سيارات الاسعاف و
طواقم الدفاع المدني الى الاماكن التي
تعرض يتعرض فيها المواطنون لاطلاق النار
نتيجه
الاشتباكات حقيقه يعني ايه على قضيه
الطواقم الطبيه والطواقم الصحفيه يعانون
من الوصول لاماكن الاستهداف تحديدا منذ
السابع من اكتوبر ايه زادت وتيره استهداف
الطواقم الطبيه
وايضا طواقم الدفاع البدني ومنعهم بشكل
مباشر وتحت تهديد السلاح في بعض الاحيان
ايه اثناء اقتحامات الاحتلال للمدن
والمخيمات الفلسطينيه منع لتحرك مركبات
الاسعاف يقوم الاحتلال بتفتيش بعض مركبات
الاسعاف اثناء دخولها الى المستشفى او
احيانا اثناء خروجها ومحاوله وصولها الى
المخيم بعض في بعض الاحيان يكون هناك ت
تفتيش لعده مرات لنفس مركبه الاسعاف على
نفس الطريق وهذا
يعني يقع في اطار الاستهداف المتواصل
والمتزايد منذ السابع من اكتوبر بحق
الطواقم الصحفيه منذ السابع ايضا منذ
السابع من اكتوبر منع او يمنع الاحتلال
ويحاول منع الطواقم الصحفيه من او الطواقم
الطبيه عفوا من الد د الى المخيمات
اثناء الاقتحام قبل الاقتحام السابق كان
هناك اعتداء على الطواقم الطبيه كان هناك
اعتقال لاحد الطواقم او عناصر الطواقم
الطبيه من امام مستشفى او من امام
عفوا مخيم مخيم طول كرم حيث قام الاحتلال
بايقاف المركبه وقام باعتقال احد طواقم او
الطواقم الطبيه الطواقم او طواقم الدفاع
المدني يحاول الاحتلال في كل مره وفي كل
اقتحام منعهم من التقدم والوصول نحو
المخيمات بالرغم من انه انه يكون هناك
اشارات بوجود لاشعال نار في احد المنازل
لكن الطواقم او الاحتلال يمنع هذه الطواقم
من الوصول ونحن نشاهد واياك مرور ايضا
سيارات الاسعاف اريد ان نوه الى الخبر
العاجل اذا مراسلنا قوات الاحتلال تحاصر
مخيم نور شمس وتتمركز عند داخله الرئيسيه
وسط اشتباكات والقاء عبوات ناسفه اذا وكنا
قد رصدنا لحظات اقتحام قوات الاحتلال
مدينه طول كرم شمال الضفه الغربيه في من
محورها ال الغربي واستمر في هذه اللحظات
معك مراسلنا الياث ليث جعار من طول كرم
ليث بالنسبه
ل هذه الاعداد من السيارات
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه في عمليه
الاقتحام هل لمستم تغيير في هذه القوه
المقتحمه هذه المره قياسا على ما جرى في
المرات
السابقه نعم يعني في هذه المره حقيقه ما
تم
رصده من تغير ملحوظ في اليات الاحتلال هو
دخول عدد من جرافات في كل اقتحام يكون
هناك جرافه واحده من طراز دي 9 وايضا
جرافه عجلات تقوم بفتح الطريق وازاله
العوائق والحواجز التي تضعها المقاومه في
هذا الاقتحام تم رصد عبر الهواء مباشره
جرافتين من طراز دي 9 وايضا جرافتين من
طراز او من طراز العجلات التي وصلت في
الدفعه الاولى الى مخيم نور شمس ومن ثم
قبل قليل وصلت الدفعه الثانيه نحو المخيم
ايضا من الامور الملحوظه هو عشرات او وجود
عشرات الجنود الراجلين في حي الرشيد الى
الجنوب من المخيم والتي في هذه اللحظات
تقوم باقتحام المخيم مشيا على الاقدام
وسط طيران الاستطلاع الذي لا يزال يجوب
شوارع المدينه شكرا لك مراسلنا ليث جعار
من طول كرم شكرا
لك y